Jungs noch Farben ich muss einmal kurz
unterbrechen und wir schalten zu unserer
Kollegin Angelika Hellemann denn bei ihr
steht Olaf Scholz sie hat ihn jetzt im
Interview und da hören wir natürlich
hier in unserer Runde auch gespannt rein
Angelika
hallo Herr Scholz die Wähler haben
entschieden wie sicher sind Sie
eigentlich dass sie wirklich auch der
nächste Kanzler von Deutschland werden
ich habe sehr früh gesagt dass ich
kandidiere die SPD hat mich aufgestellt
und jetzt sehen wir ein Ergebnis mit dem
lange viele nicht gerechnet haben die
SPD ist stärkste Partei geworden nach
den aktuellen Hochrechnungen die SPD
kann daraus auch ableiten die nächsten
Kanzler zu stellen und ich merke ja auch
dass das was sich in dem Wahlergebnis
niederschlägt was zu tun hat auch mit
den Umfragen die zeigen viele wünschen
sich auch dass ich die nächste Regierung
Bilde und führe und cdu/csu sind
abgewählt aber Herr Laschet zieht aus
diesem Ergebnis auch irgendwie die Idee
eine zukunftskoalition mit FDP und
Grünen bilden zu können die Balken sind
nach oben gegangen bei den Meldungen
über die Wahl bei der SPD über den
Grünen und auch bei der FDP aber bei der
CDU ganz besonders sind sie massiv nach
unten gegangen das ist eine klare
Botschaft der Wählern und Wähler niemand
möchte das jetzt eine solche
Regierungskoalition zustande kommt also
für sie wäre es ein Buch oder ein
Verstoß gegen den Wähler will wenn Armin
Laschet Bundeskanzler werden würde der
Wähler Wille ist jedenfalls sehr
eindeutig und deshalb gibt es jetzt
darum ganz pragmatisch und sehr
ordentlich darüber zu reden wie Parteien
zusammenkommen können die dann eine
Regierung bilden und da geht es dann
darum dass wir dafür sorgen dass mehr
Respekt in unserer Gesellschaft herrscht
dass wir die industrielle Modernisierung
Zustande kriegen die jetzt notwendig ist
damit wir nicht in 10 20 30 Jahren
traurig dem Wohlstand auf anderen
Kontinenten zuschauen und es geht
natürlich darum den Menschen gemachten
Klimawandel aufzuhalten
jetzt kommt hier morgen früh das
Präsidium und der Parteivorstand
zusammen was für ein Verhandlungsmandat
wollen sie sich geben lassen wir wollen
schnell eine Regierung bilden und wir
wollen gute Ergebnisse erzielen das was
ich überall auf den Marktplätzen in
Deutschland gesagt habe was ich ändern
muss in Deutschland das möchte ich auch
erreichen und das halte ich auch für
sehr gut möglich wie schnell müssen sich
denn wem sie in Koalitionsverhandlungen
einsteigen also ob mit Armin Laschet
oder mit Olaf Scholz
es geht darum dass hier alle zusammen
tun und ihren Beitrag leisten dass das
was die Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich
wünschen auch realisiert wird und
deshalb bin ich sicher dass dies ein
klares plebeszitäres Votum für eine
Regierungsbildung ist um die ich mich
mit anderen Parteien bemühen kann sie
haben bei der Berliner Runde
Janina Bärbel
dran gesprochen oder haben Sie sich
schon verabredet wann sie sich mal
zusammensetzen wollen wir haben uns
schon unterhalten auch nicht nur
öffentlich im Fernsehen und trotzdem
glaube ich nicht dass es sich gehört das
über die Dinge die wir damit aneinander
bereden jetzt öffentlich geredet wird
aber sie haben heute miteinander schon
gesprochen wie man oder wann man und wir
haben miteinander geredet
gut jetzt ist es ja aber so dass sie zum
Beispiel sagen ohne zwölf Euro
Mindestlohn im ersten Jahr ihrer
Kanzlerschaft das würden sie so nicht
mitmachen wie wollen Sie denn eigentlich
Christian Lindner dazu bewegen heute
Abend wird noch ausgezählt und dann
werden wir morgen uns daran machen wir
eine Regierung zu bilden und für mich
ist wichtig dass die Dinge die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich wünschen von
einer künftigen Regierung auch umgesetzt
werden aber Koalitionsverhandlungen
führt man mit möglichen
Koalitionspartnern nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit und haben sie Angst dass
die Grünen sie dann erpresst weil die
wir können ja auch immer antworten wir
können auch Jamaika machen und der Armin
der gibt uns übrigens gerade beim
Klimaschutz sehr sehr viel mehr das
finden wir gerade einfach attraktiver
oder da bekommen wir ein Ministerium
mehr meine Überzeugung ist das Politik
auch darin besteht dass man das tut was
die Bürger und Bürger mit ihrer
Stimmabgabe von einem erwarten und ich
bin sicher alle werden das sehr
konstruktiv voranbringen jedenfalls ist
das der Auftrag den wir heute gekriegt
haben ich werde mich an ihn halten und
ich bin sicher andere auch und mit wem
stoßen sie heute Abend noch an auf das
Wahlergebnis
ich habe schon mit vielen angestoßen
wenn auch mit einem alkoholfreien Bier
bisher das gehört ja zum Wahlkampf dazu
und zu den großen Herausforderungen die
jetzt vor uns stehen und natürlich hoffe
ich dass wenn alles zu Ende ist ich auch
noch mal Zeit habe mit meiner Frau
diesen Tag miteinander auszuwerden aber
danke geworden
[Musik]